[Music]
who here
has played around with their reels
i mean i just looked at the features i
didn't do anything i hadn't created
anything
we haven't everyone has access to reels
i don't guess that
i don't feel like it's real yet no pun
intended like i don't feel like it's
really it's not i can't
point does it become real i think i
think i think when
video starts to go viral via real
be your reals okay yeah is it reals or
real real
yeah so i think one really big real
really a differentiating factor between
reals
and then tick tock is so tick tock
people are really um not genuine
reeling people in yeah yeah they're not
they're not
i don't know if genuine's the right word
but you know how like uh when youtube
first started there's this
authentic authenticity of just being
just raw and it just felt like figuring
it out
yeah it's it's not as produced and
branded as instagram and i think that's
the charm of tickets yeah
it's literally like people just it's his
own thing dancing with their mom yeah
it's his own thing it doesn't come it
doesn't compete with anything well
that's how a lot of people felt about
snapchat
too but then snapchat is like
practically dead
stories yeah exactly it's not dead with
the premium snapchat community who likes
to sell
boobs for sorry i forgot about it it's
very
popping it's very on and alive
especially the premium community yeah
the premium buy my premium i'll put that
in my bio buy my premium
i've had a lot of dudes ask me to make
an only fans really yeah
what would you join your only fans i
have no [ __ ] idea just
maybe just like boxer shorts maybe just
oh [ __ ]
you go the sexual route yeah just
straight ass shots and boxers yeah
yeah like any nipple action
maybe yeah maybe damn i've been giving
it out for free
yeah bro yeah dude somewhere out there
there's a market just for you
i know i've been asked i've been
asked i don't know if it's worth the
money
i mean people are buying houses with
only fans i mean you can build an empire
it's crazy i've heard crazy anyways uh
so tick tock uh and reels are going
to battle as of now uh so instagram
has launched a thing called reels and
it's basically their version of a tick
tock
and it's embedded in instagram it looks
exactly the same
you can you can edit stuff but music
they have a whole like list of licenses
everything everything use somebody
else's audio everything's
up yeah i thought it was weird when i
started looking at my feed and a lot of
videos could pop in because i'm used to
seeing videos
in my feed be ig tv videos
but and then like it has a location at
the top but now it says original audio
and i'm like what i got so confused
about that because i didn't realize that
it was reals
you know what i thought is that when you
scroll it's not just your friends now
it's it's other people
and i think really yeah i was crazy i
was like who's this
who's this who's this and i think that's
going to help people grow yeah
that's why that's why that's that's why
tick tock is so strong bro because you
scroll and come across
random people i love it yeah it's kind
of like youtube
how it used to be on the front page when
it would just be like random things
now it's like what you search and what
you like to watch and [ __ ] right i hate
that but instagram changed too the
algorithm's all [ __ ] up yeah because
it's not even in order of when it gets
posted like i'll post something but then
maybe you'll
it'll you'll receive it like seven hours
later there's friends that i follow that
i haven't even seen their posts in a
month
yeah they just don't show it to me
there's times where i'll see i'll see
like
a post and it could be you at six i was
like what a [ __ ] six blacks today and
it says three days ago and i'm like what
yeah that's great i hate it algorithm
yeah i know i was like stick
why did they change it because it used
to be better it might be better to um
for like advertising like selling it or
something they might be
tracking it i have this conspiracy hat
idea
where if i put it on i'm like i wonder
how tight
zuckerberg and donald trump are and does
donald trump own any shares
of facebook or instagram and he's like
hey
if i can get rid of tick tock you guys
build the new reels
do your shares go up which means my
shares go up because i have
i was thinking about that i swear to god
i was thinking about that exact thing
yeah like what you're saying i feel like
there another angle's attack conspiracy
is maybe trump is really good friends
with bill gates even there's that cause
now it's coming to light that microsoft
is the number one contender to buy out
tick-tock
and they have tick-tock be an
american-owned company now which would
make it legal
yeah which would make it illegal i don't
know if he's friends with just the
american side
just the american side like amer america
us
i think canada and some other [ __ ]
some other cool countries so isn't he
gonna ban it
in like 40 days or some [ __ ] tick tock
trump
actually i just i found an article that
was published today
trump effectively bans tick tock and
wechat with executive orders he just did
that today
uh chinese-made apps like tick-tock are
a national emergency
nothing popped up they said can't
connect but i'm on airplane mode i'm
like [ __ ] it's gone
just like that i think it's like there's
like 40 days or something
40 days yeah they probably have time
they need time
transition it to another i think it's
like september september 15th or
something so basically
uh with microsoft trying to buy uh
buyout tick tock
they have until that september date two
finished negotiations
to buy it out and then that's also the
same date that tick tock will be
banned in america i don't think he's
zuckerberg's trump zuckerberg's
friend because um recently
he sent out this [ __ ] saying wait no no
sorry never mind it was bernie not trump
you saw that thing where bernie was um
trying to do a one-time tax
for bezos and zuckerberg of like 20
billion yeah
yeah yeah yeah i know it's crazy wild
yeah
guess how much tocs worth how much
microsoft is trying to negotiate i don't
know billions
i don't know definitely in the billions
you don't get the guess you see this
right now already yeah
i'm gonna take a good guess [ __ ] i'm
thinking uh
three billion i'm 20 billion i guess
because instagram got bought from one
billion by facebook
so i'm thinking it's gotta be more than
that so it's like 10 billion so
so the three is in there 300 billion no
13.
30
[Music]
basically the high is 30 billion and the
low is at 10 billion
and that's what's being reported right
now so they're negotiating in that range
and did you say instagram was purchased
for a billion yeah
that's already huge but that was a long
time ago already too
oh you're right you're right that was
like almost 10 years ago uh garyvee
say that uh facebook stole instagram
he's he's like he's like facebook stole
instagram they only bought it for a
billion
which is the point what was his point
the instagram founders were pissed
they they walked away from instagram i
think like and like
or i don't know if they were pissed but
like i remember there was something
yes oh yeah because i guess they figured
they could be worth more
you know and they're like this could
have been two yeah i forgot i forgot
where i've seen it but yeah i've seen a
gary video he's like so you're saying it
was undervalued yeah he's like he's like
he
he captioned this video facebook stole
instagram and everybody was like what
confused and he explained it and i was
like
i mean i mean at that time i'm just like
oh maybe you want to feel better drink
some of my wine
yeah and like yeah yeah go to the wine
library yeah and now it's like
yeah [ __ ] he's right i feel like
instagram could have sold for way more
30 billion i mean come on
sucks about these things too or i don't
know i mean this is part of business i
don't just part of this i don't
understand but
when these companies get sold at these
huge levels it's not like any of the
creators get any trickle-down money
yeah you know like it's not like a tick
tocker or you get 10 g's or 100 g's
which it could be nothing it'd be nice
but you know what i feel like
i feel like where where vine [ __ ] up
is where is that
with tick-tock right you get bot or
whatever but tick-tock
is an app that actually allows you to
grow you know i mean so it's like you're
really working for yourself like
you can grow organically which would
bring you brand deals
on vine after a while bro like you
stopped growing like it's like it was
the algorithm was changed it was
different you know so maybe that's tic
tocs way of giving back to the creator
like
as long as you put in the work you'll
grow like it's not like you're limited
you know what i mean
i know maybe that's my that's my for
these top tier creators though
um if they're like like i'm talking
about like the a
level uh creators like instagram or tick
tock or
earth trill i think um they all give
each other
they all give them uh like creator money
like they're like if you only post
exclusively here i heard of one deal of
uh one of them getting like a hundred
thousand dollars just to like
exclusively post on like instagram or
whatever all of them do like
patreon like if you're at that high
level everyone has like
ninja what did he get he got 30 million
i forgot you got 30 million to stream on
this other streaming
the other one not twitch not twitch
another one yeah
twitch took away his verification the
same day damn
they were salty they were mad yeah yeah
that's true like joe rogan too right
he jumped he hopped off 100 million 200
million 100 million for uh where's the
spotify
that's some good money that is some good
money bro i need to just
stop being lazy and do something huh
wait it's always
tick-tock i need to raise my value dude
for real dude
get on that reels [ __ ] i'm about to
reels for reals
um is tick-tock created was that created
by
the chinese government or just someone
in china like a company in china
i don't know i don't know i know it used
to be musically right wait wait wait
talk was music was musically yeah
i don't know the parent company is a
chinese conglomerate yeah the chinese
parent company
is bite dance yeah so they're not didn't
they just make a second vine called bite
oh i don't even know yes they there is
so so
a lot of people are saying reals is
coming in very late in the game because
there's a lot of
other companies that are uh trying to do
the same thing that tick tock has
success with so
bite is one of them b-y-t-e dub smash
and triller yeah they're all like
tick-tock uh similar type products
reels really
and how seamlessly it's being integrated
into the entire app because before with
igtv it used to be like a separate app
or like in a separate like it was kind
of hard to find igtv and it wouldn't pop
up in your feed so that's why
gtv didn't really pick up that fast
picture with igtv i i can't remember but
if you scroll does it show your the
people you follow or
other people i think it's like oh it's
other people too okay yeah
well at least before i don't know about
now yeah but instagram took out
vine and they took out snapchat yeah so
yeah now they're about to take off
with a little help from the american
government yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i think that's why i could also
see tick tock uh
reels being successful because it
because bro it's a it's a [ __ ] black
hole tick thought you
just hours and hours and hours and i
feel like with
rios now that can happen too because you
can go scroll like oh it's funny who's
this
and then now you go to my instagram page
and you follow me so
maybe i should start doing reels
but yeah based on what we're just saying
right now too
a lot of people are kind of uh
speculating that
instagram is launching reels at the same
time that trump is trying to shut down
tick tock and so that it's all like a
planned
maneuver to take out tick-tock and to
take over this
this uh creative spectrum of uh i guess
creating these videos right
could be planned or could be right
opportunity at the right time
yeah and that's what instagram is saying
yeah like we've been planning this for
over a year and like we couldn't foresee
that tick tock was going to be
close everything's connected
everything i'm a conspiracy theory now
bro because we all are
conspiracy like i've been watching so
many videos i'm like huh
you don't believe [ __ ] yeah you don't
know what to believe now god connects to
this dot then they must connect to them
it makes sense like like i i came across
a couple dudes on instagram that are
conspiracy theorists and i'm like
like i can see that that makes sense
you know because before i used to see
him like oh my god [ __ ] not
everything is
a conspiracy and now i'm just like
everything everything might be a
conspiracy though
everything's connected somehow it's
crazy it's so
fun to play with it from from [ __ ]
reels to
[ __ ] kobit everything's connected
somehow bro somehow it's kind of
seriously i believe
it's crazy i'm gonna shut up because i
don't want to [ __ ] die by suicide
yeah i don't want that by suicide i'ma
shut up hello guys thank you guys so
much for watching all of our videos and
i know it's been a million years in the
making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around
jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]